okay so the second secret Invasion
trailer is now out and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down the
brand new look talking about the Easter
eggs hidden details and also giving off
theories on what could be happening in
the show I actually recently reread the
run and it's a far cry from the
political thriller that we see in this
series centered heavily Around The
Avengers this had a Monumental knock-on
effect with the rest of the Marvel
Universe it's happened at a point in
which they were at their lowest in the
aftermath of Civil War Tony Stark was
tricked into thinking he may be a scroll
and we found out that several of this
species had infiltrate the ranks of the
Marvel Universe bloody Jarvis is one now
in the MCU it's coming off the back of
Avengers end game and it could be argued
that the universe is at one of its
lowest points as well people just don't
seem to be as enamored with the MCU as
they used to be and with model Studios
going through a lot of drama behind the
scenes this may be the perfect time for
a show like this to come along the
political thriller seems to be more in
line with the Winter Soldier and though
it's a Far Cry from its comic book
counterpart I think this could be just
what we need right now anyway the first
trailer opened with Nick Fury returning
to Earth which is where he was reunited
with Maria Hill maybe cast your mind
back to far from home then you'll
remember that he was off wheel for some
time with Talos and his wife
masquerading in his Maria's place we
discovered that he'd been avoiding Earth
for years and it's difficult to say
whether that was even him at the end of
end game the calls have been going
straight to voicemail and Nick Fury is
being ghosting everyone to make up the
Spider-Man ghosting him who knows this
series we might even find out who
Spider-Man Actually is as he's the only
hero in the MCU that we don't know the
secret identity of a fury looks down
trodden and beaten and it could show how
long he's been off-world and this idea
of him being called back to Earth for
some serious business is of course
reminiscent of why Captain Marvel had to
return at the end of infinity war man's
even arming up his wife who we know will
be played by Charlene wooded he's even
coming back to Earth to see her so it
must be important like hitting the
Subscribe button on the channel That
occasionally posts alright videos
Since You've Been Gone
she's gotten much worse
how do you think I came back
[Music]
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us
a friend
[Music]
this is personal
now we start the new look off very much
building off the back of the previous
trailer with him walking through the
woods there's a number of things that
this could be to such as a secret Shield
facility or one of his many hideouts
looking at the rest of the trailer and
the clothes he has on though I think
this might actually be to the tombs that
we see later on though he also goes to
one of his gravestones it's important to
point out that he's wearing a gray hat
here and a slightly different coat in
both the opening shot on the one at the
tomb he he's wearing a purple hat and
this is possibly linking them both
together the trailer also ends with him
walking out of that so they might be
bringing it full circle from the
beginning and showing the start of that
scene and then the end of it with anger
tell us saying that things have been
getting much worse since he's been gone
it's actually difficult to tell how long
this has been going on for and it's
possible that he might have disappeared
completely out of the events of Winter
Soldier and him returning to Earth here
is his first time back on the planet
since then really difficult to tell and
though it has been said that he came
back for endgame we just don't really
know now from here we go to Moscow and
see the Kremlin this is then attacked by
Kingsley benedia's character and we know
that he's gonna be called gravic judging
by how his arms change later on it's
possible that he's a super scroller and
I'm guessing that he's gonna be the
leader of the resistance group or is he
well I think he's at least the face and
they could definitely put it where they
problem up as the bad guy and then
reveal that it's actually one of the
characters that we've grown to trust
either way this is clearly the face of
the Scrolls of chosen where when they're
carrying out their attacks due to their
well-being shape-shifters it's possible
that these are all different Scrolls but
they want to appear as this one man in a
similar way to how a group like
Anonymous all wear those V for Vendetta
masks we actually see Maria in the
middle of this attack and it's possible
that this kick starts the season and
then this is why she reaches out to Nick
sorry Fury I'm guessing that friends
call him Fury out now I'm guessing that
in this they realize it's the Scrolls
and then Fury finds out about it which
is why he returns to Earth now already
being brought back in is a big edition
of the show and for years now people
have suspected that he's a scroll it's
been a big Theory time that people have
had for for over 10 years now and if you
go back and look at what the character
looked like in the first Iron Man movie
you may notice that there's something
slightly different about him yep that's
right he has a mustache but him not
having one after that movie could show
that he's been switched out with a
scroll the other ones we met in Captain
Marvel were friendly in the comics
they're almost always the bad guys and
they could be attempting to shift them
back to being villains for the rest of
the Saga scrolls are refugees and from
what we know in the show they will be
trying to claim our planet as their own
this is why they've taken spots and lots
of leadership positions and have started
replay saw people with their own it's
something they did in the comics too and
it gave them access to our technology
and weapons now just like how Hydra had
infiltrated Shield we now have an alien
invasion happening in the US government
it's very much a cold war going on on
the planet and in opposition to this we
have mi-13 based in the UK this
secretive entity deals with paranormal
and Supernatural activities it's
England's answer to shield and the
organization probably no fury due to him
being the ex-director ahead of it will
be played by Olivia Coleman now we also
know that she's gonna be called Sonia
falsworth I love it if it was revealed
that she was a Skrill as well and this
would add an extra dimension on top of
everything you already have division in
them as we have Talos on one side and
then the resistance sect that are trying
to take over everything now we also know
that the character actually has roots in
the Marvel Universe too and she's
actually the descendant of James
Montgomery falsworth AKA Union Jack
anyway this will all be going down in
London which is where Fury ends up
meeting up with her we then see them
traveling out to his grave and you might
notice that this is actually different
one to the one at the end of winter
soldier the inscription in that was a
reference to Pulp Fiction whereas this
one reads Greater Love had no man than
this that a man laid on his life for his
friends potentially the real Fury is
dead and this guy is also a scrub now
what I think this most likely is is that
this is out in England and they may also
faked his death with mi-13 we can also
see from the tomb site that he uses
Graves as a place to hide things out so
potentially this is a literal Dead Drop
that has his equipment he then cut to
the indoor site and we can see that
there's a wolf emblem on it this is lit
up showing that it's activated whereas
in the next shot when he arms up it's
powered down Easter egg but I'm just
being thorough mate very few of us know
about the wars fought in the shadows
that have raged on this planet
[Music]
you feel responsible
where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you now next week at the characters
walking through cityscapes and we hear
about their secret wars fought in the
shadows we can catch Ben Mendelson's
Talus saying something and I'm guessing
that this is an exposition dump to catch
us up on what's been happening since
he's been away however it Ross as
someone who's gonna be returning as well
he's of course on the run after the
events of wakanda forever and now he's
lying low after being double crossed by
his ex-wife it's always the bloody wives
and Ross being revealed to be a scroll
would be a big thing for the series and
he is the kind of character that I
imagine them to pull this kind of twist
on I need these kinds of names where
it's gonna be a shock but it's not gonna
retroactively destroy everything and he
fits them all pretty well man was
married to a higher ranking US
government official and he became one
himself making him the ideal candidate
to be revealed as a scroll now from here
we get an overhead shot of a convoy and
this is following on from the same one
that's later shot up by a helicopter we
know that Emilia Clarke's character will
be there too and she seems to be slumped
over a body potentially this is Talos
and it may be a big moment in the show
in which he dies now as for Amelia
Clarke there's actually a lot that's
been announced since the last teaser
Disney have come out and told us exactly
who she's gonna be yeah we now know that
she's gonna be playing Gear this is a
character who pulls from the comics and
then that she and her fellow agent Chloe
lived on Earth and had a family one of
their donors was taken by project
Blossom there were big things that
happened with them in the source
material gear posters pepperbots at one
point and she's had quite a big history
with the Scrolls that spans back years
in the show though this is actually
going to be tell us his daughter who was
first introduced at the end of Captain
Marvel we of course also met Monica
Rambo in that as well so we've seen
these two kids grow up off the back of
that film it's even possible that gear
was a scroll we met at the end of one
Division and this would sign with him
meeting her after seeing her mother when
she was younger also it might be
pronounced Gaia if it is it's sorry
again I think it I think it's actually
Gaia
and that's kind of why I think she's
leaning over the body of him and if
Talus is taken out and it means Fury's
list of allies is getting smaller and
smaller later on in the teaser we catch
him badly injured and that sort of looks
like a black vehicle behind him
potentially linking these two moments up
now after this shot we see several
bodies on beds seemingly in hibernation
this is the room that Gaia came across
in the first trailer and we see a
follow-on from that scene with her
looking over them my guess is that she's
discovered a place that is potentially
holding the world leaders who've been
replaced by Scrolls and we may come
across some of the characters we know
here I was singing that the Scrolls may
be sucking DNA around them to make
duplicates but Scrolls can shape-shift
without taking a person's bodily through
it so I'm guessing they'd not need to do
that Sonia then asks if Fury feels
responsible and this is likely because
he helped the squirrels initially on
Earth off and now they've thrown
a revolution now the secret Invasion
comic storyline was a major event
spanning several books in it we picked
up in the aftermath of Civil War and
Nick Fury discovered that Valentina
Allegre de Fontaine was in fact one they
could do this with her in the MCU too
and it might explain her sudden turn
against Everett however I am leaning
more towards him being one over here as
we know that she's gonna play a big part
in the Thunderbolts anyway Fury went
into hiding after discovering the truth
and he ended up sending in his best age
in Spiderwoman to go into shield and spy
on things Spider Woman hey now she was
revealed to be a scroll herself though
and this could potentially be taken over
by Maria in the show we know a scroll
has posed to say before and maybe
there's not even a Maria Hill and she's
just been a scroll all along now when
this was going on Tony was in charge of
Shield after the events of Civil War
this is why the Scrolls try to convince
him that he was in fact one and to be
fair it almost worked in the end they
launched their attack over the Savage
land and also dropped one in the middle
of New York several characters were
revealed to be shapeshifters and this
included Hank Pym Jarvis Mockingbird dum
dum in and of course Spider Woman though
the heroes won in the end National
Security was never the same and it held
major ramifications for groups refusing
to come together down the line because
no one knew who to trust and the trailer
we then cut to what I believe is Paris
we see someone walking the streets and
then a paper from the globe discussing
the Battle of New York we hear our voice
asking where the Avengers are and at
this point they are very much a
fractured group Spider-Man is back to
being a friendly neighborhood one Iron
Man is dead and Steve Rogers is being
President Joe Biden they then see gravic
from behind and he walks into a room
with a giant device in the middle
guessing that this is his sort of
McGuffin world-ending device thing that
the villains have their hands on and
it's now about to go down we later on
seen abandoned power plant and I'm
guessing this could be where it's
located at this could be in Russia as
well because stereotypes now one point
gravic hits Fury when they're both
standing inside of it so this may be
where a lot of things go down at Nick
Fury is very much talking about going
off on his own and we see how alone that
he now is I love this shot where he's
stopped in the corridor and you know I
keep saying everyone's either a scroll
or Mephisto but this guy they have to be
screw remember there's one for fist over
a guy who says that the Scrolls have
something planned for him and going back
to the comics they basically wanted to
replace him and get access to all the
security measures that he had this would
allow them to truly rule over Earth and
they'd not really have anything stopping
them from taking over Nick Fury promised
them that he'd find them a place to live
but he's very much forgotten about them
and thus they've started to put things
in place to take our planet for their
own
Great Neck Fury
all right
one last fight
now in this part of the trailer we see a
suitcase which has a damage control logo
on it they've of course popped up in the
MC quite a lot recently and we can't
tell from this that they've obtained a
specimen of something this might be
scroll DNA and potentially it could
allow them to detect Scrolls in advance
with NC Sonia going to torture someone
and gravic looking out of a Milky window
potentially at the abandoned Factory
that popped it before now after this we
have a rooftop Chase and lots of action
scenes you also get a moment where I
believe Nick's wife might be standing
behind Gaia but let me know below
exactly what you think anyway we close
out the trailer with more action before
Fury finally walks out on his own he's
very much fighting the battles by
himself and we're gonna finally see if
the man truly lives up to the legend I'm
nice like that anyway that's the trailer
and as are my thoughts you know Disney
need to win right now uh let's be honest
and this looks like something that could
in fact deliver that Disney Plus shows
are always a bit hit and miss I think
it's mainly towards the end of the
series I think things start to fall
apart so I'm hoping that this comes with
consequences just like how lucky did
they have a lot of potential to hit us
with some gut punches here and revealing
some of our favorite characters are
Scrolls would be a good way to go about
this the thing about the original secret
Invasion run was that it was just packed
with you constantly being like who's
this girl who's a squirrel and if they
can keep it on top of that then I think
the series is really gonna work it is a
political thriller more in line with the
Winter Soldier and with that being one
of the best MCU movies ever made they
have a lot of things that they can do
here so yeah potentials there will they
deliver let's hope so and yeah next
project in Phase five it needs to be a
banger obviously at allowed to hear your
thoughts on it are you excited yep
comment below and let me know we are an
income Edition right now giving away the
Superman 4K box set to 3 subscribers on
the 15th of April and all you have to do
to be when the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
if you want something else to watch you
got another video on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been Paul I'll
see you next time take care peace